everyone where I gamescom 2015 and i'm
joined by Daniel Dwyer who just saw
Assassin's Creed syndicate almost called
a victory there did you change your name
now it's a new dawn for a sorceress in
London London Bailey pedro by you clean
it come on your chimney governor as a
London I find out offensive to me mate
you're as long back no no no that's not
what Bodie we've seized on the neighbors
this game is not take place in one of
the streets of leytonstone yeah for my
level I took place in Terra London car
London yes the most popularly touristed
or visited touristy thing which no one
in London's ever been to know have you
ever been there I have not amazing than
my entire yep Terrill on the beefeaters
no no well you can now in Assassin's
Creed syndicate got it almost all right
so I played this game right run I'm a
semi to this demo I was kind of
wondering why am I being sent to this
demo because I have been on a massive
downer with Assassin's Creed for the
past three Black Flag interesting
everything since then I've been kind of
like all right you guys are struggling
with this annual release the biggest
problem I've had is that they make these
beautiful worlds and like Paris was
amazing unity and then not the levels of
admissions are just so triton on
interesting and there's so many of them
and it's like God if you just made like
half the levels and and just made like
the actual missions interesting i'd be
into it that was the most fun of our
Assassin's Creed in about three years
well I enjoyed about this it was
probably the level that I saw so why why
saw was and the Tower of London that's
one of these black box missions they had
in unity but true you can tell that
they've really focused on it so
basically what this is is it's one of
these missions story missions which are
basically sort of cut off in the wider
world you go in there once you get
inside you sort of hit like a
synchronization point and then you see
all of this stuff all these things
happening so I've got a target one of
these buildings but then three or four
others sort of like innocuous things in
fact one of the captains is has been put
in a jail there's a guy walking around
with the keys that'll open everything
yeah there's somebody else who's found
that there's some of the beefeaters of
turn our Templars in the skies and you
can basically run in straight away if
you want and try and kill this target
and which feels like the sort of like
it's like great Assassin's Creed one
feeling of all of this is here but what
I'm really here to do is like get down
universal yeah and or if you want you
can scale up out the place is figure out
at the better way in or you can go after
one of these optional second requests or
whatever I want to call it was the thing
that they introduced in unit yes and it
seems like I saw this at Ubisoft Quebec
recently and it did seem like they had
refined it and create more interesting
environments and also their little
pieces the cause they are turning a
little
interesting yes yeah it's almost like it
feels like a contained hitman mission
exactly that's exactly how I felt and it
did so because some of the things are
very specific like for one there was
like and there was three things I could
do I get unlock this guy in a room and
that involved you know going in creeping
about maybe killing one or two guys and
then like talking to them these like all
the keys downstairs and trying to find
the key and it's like it's that great
thing in game is lanix I'm like The
Witcher 3 does really well which is like
taking all individual components like
stealth which works really well
especially Evie [ __ ] she's very
interesting South wise and taking like
the assassinating taking world
exploration with their new grappling
hook which I resolved and adding it all
together and making like a real sort of
a enjoyable like a couple of different
gameplay mechanics touching each other
so like that that was one thing another
thing was looking for the keys they're
just walking around and but that's cook
then you like it's that hitman thing we
like you're stepping back in right okay
if I get him here it'll be easiest you
and I did that and then the other thing
was was this guard who knows that some
of the beefeaters are actually you know
Templars in the skies right and then you
can ask if you do a couple of things for
him you basically were like be in
cahoots with you and like pretend which
are a prisoner and bring you in and it's
like I you know I have I have a feeling
that I hadn't habit Assassin's Creed in
the world which is usually when I played
those games every mission I do I'm like
getting it over with so I can get to a
level that I love them I'll enjoy I
completed this level dodge I'm gonna go
back and try it a different way I
haven't felt our disaster school
definitely feel donkeys yeah it
definitely feels more dynamic for the
big thing that they revealed at Gamescom
is easy we haven't seen much of her in
the pot has been a big focus on Jacob
and he's been a typical Assassin's Creed
type Erykah he's been boisterous yeah he
got aggressive in combat the v's the the
kind of unknown quantity yes Moshe like
what her key advantages you know
was it like playing so the brother to me
Jacob right he reminds me of a very
petty I didn't I differenza he's like a
like a brush kind of ever or like I
don't know like sort of a personable and
I'll tie year my favorite assassin mine
too yeah right kind of a dick Martin but
he he had this sort of like send to it
yeah that he was alone yeah and that the
s all these other assassins for that but
he was on his own question Evie kind of
feels like that she brings the tradition
of the assassins she's much more
interested in like keeping the
traditions in the past and that loss
really yeah so I think she's a good yang
sir to Jacobs yang I liked her in terms
of abilities she has this like ability
to basically kind of turn invisible
right you can like she puts her hood up
and then she kind of goes a bit opaque
as it signified to the player that
you're visible but it's basically like
she's blended in really good which is
handy if you've just been caught you can
you know run around a corner find
somewhere and I'm trying my hung curd
add her combat abilities apparently
different I couldn't read tags didn't
get to be Jacob tonight and what as a
character I found are interesting what I
also had anything was at this black box
level is about her trying to get a piece
of evening so it's a super assassinate
wall and Paul totally right and she's
doing this you can swap between the two
of them in the open world yeah and for
missions and stuff like that this is her
heart of it he's gonna have his own
missions and she's gonna have our own
missions I like that about the dynamic
between them is really interesting to me
because what you say about her being
more in touch with the classical you
know the roots of the assassins it's
kind of like the journey the character
off that Ezio talk yes when he started
off as Jacob the brush I have don't
really care about somethings I'm in it
to win it but then by the end of it you
know he's got a beard and his since
peaked out I'll pay his library and he's
come to like be comfortable with his
origins the origins of her hair I was
actually surprised i enjoyed other's
minds I days I think like the character
stuff we'll we'll see how interesting
that is hopefully it plays out as good
it's just the attention to detail to try
and make a mission that is enjoyable to
replay was something that i also finally
remember from previous games that i
haven't felt in a long time and it
really makes me I'll say I'm cautiously
optimistic whereas before i was quite
pessimistic about Assassin's Creed
syndicate got it there you are for more
on Assassin's Creed syndicate and other
games we've seen at Gamescom keep it
gamespot
you